I'm writing this under an appreciable
mental strain since by tonight I shall
be no more penniless and at the end of
my supply of the drunk which alone makes
life endurable I can bear the torture no
longer and shall cast myself from this
garrote window into the squalid street
below to not think from my slavery to
morphine that I'm a weak thing or a
degenerate when you have read these
hastily scrawled pages you may guess
though never fully realize why it is
that I must have forgetfulness or death
it was in one of the most open and the
least for Quentin parts of the broad
Pacific the packet of which I was super
cargo full of victim to the German sea
Raider the Great War was at its very
beginning in the ocean forces of the
hunt that not completely sunk to their
later degradation so their vessel was
made a legitimate prize
whilst we of her crew were treated with
all the fairness and consideration due
us as a naval prisoners so liberal
indeed was the discipline of our captors
that five days after we were taken and
managed to escape alone in a small boat
with water and provisions for good
length of time when I finally found
myself adrift and free why I had a
little idea of my surroundings never a
competent navigator I could only guess
vaguely by the summon stars that I was
somewhat south of the equator or the
longitude I knew nothing and no island
or coastline was in sight the weather
kept fair and for uncounted days I
drifted aimlessly beneath the scorching
Sun waiting either for some passing ship
or to be cast on the shores of some
habitable land
but neither ship no land appeared and I
began to despair and my solitude upon
the heaving vastness of unbroken blue
the change happened whilst I slept its
details I shall never know for my
slumber though troubled and dream
infested was continuous at last I awaked
it was to discover myself sucked into a
slimy expansive hellish black Maya was
extended about me in monotonous
undulations as far as I could see and
then which my boat they grounded some
distance away though one might well
imagine that my first sensation would be
of wonder it so prodigious and
unexpected the transformation of scenery
I was in reality more horrified than
astonished for there was in the air and
in the rotting soil a sinister quality
which chilled me to the very core the
region was putrid the carcasses of
decaying fish and of other less
describable things which I saw
protruding from the nasty mud of the
unending plain
perhaps I should not hope to convey in
mere words the unutterable hideousness
that can dwell in absolute silence and
barren immensity
there was nothing within hearing and
nothing in sight save a vast reach of
black slime in the very completeness of
the stillness and the homogeny of the
landscape oppressed me with a nauseating
fear the Sun was blazing down from a sky
which seemed to me almost black
and it's cloudless cruelty as their
reflecting the inky marsh beneath my
feet as I crawled into the stranded boat
I realized that only one theory could
explain my position through some
unprecedented volcanic upheaval a
portion of the ocean floor must have
been thrown to the surface exposing
regions which fer innumerable millions
of years had lain hidden under
unfathomable watery depths so great was
the extent of the new land which had
risen beneath me that I could not detect
the faintest noise of the surging ocean
strain my ears as I might nor were there
any sea fowl to prey upon the dead
things for several hours I sat thinking
or brooding in the boat which lay upon
its side and afforded a slight shade as
the Sun moved across the heavens as the
day progressed the ground lost some of
its stickiness and seemed likely to dry
sufficiently for traveling purposes in a
short time that night I slept but little
and the next day I made for myself a
pack containing food and water
preparatory to an overland journey in
search of the vanished sea and possible
rescue on the third morning I found the
soil dry enough to walk upon with ease
the odour of the fish was maddening but
I was too much concerned with graver
things to mine so slight and evil and
set out boldly for an unknown go
all day I forged steadily westward
guided by a faraway hummock which rose
higher than any other elevation on the
rolling desert at night I encamped and
on the following day still travelled
toward the hammock though that object
seemed scarcely nearer than when I had
first despite it by the fourth evening I
attained the base of the mound which
turned out to be much higher than it
appeared from a distance an intervening
Valley settling and out in sharper
relief from the general surface too
weary to ascend I slept in the shadow of
the hill I know not why my dreams were
so wild that night but there the waning
and fantastically gibbous moon had risen
far above the eastern plain I was awake
in a cold perspiration
determined to sleep no more such visions
as I experienced with too much for me to
endear again and in the glow of the moon
I saw how unwise I'd been to travel by
day without the glare of the parching
Sun my journey would have cost me less
energy indeed I now fell apart able to
perform the ascent which had deterred me
at sunset picking up my pack I started
for the crest of the eminence
I've said that the unbroken monotony of
the rolling plains was a source of vague
horror to me but I think my horror was
greater when I gained the summit of the
mound and looked down the other side
into an immeasurable pictur Canyon whose
black recesses the moon had not yet
soared high enough to illumine I felt
myself on the edge of the world peering
over the rim into her father was chaos
of eternal night through my terror
around curious reminiscences of Paradise
Lost and Satan's hideous climb through
the unfashionable of as the moon climbed
higher in the sky I began to see that
the slopes of the valley were not quite
so perpendicular as I had imagined
legends and outcroppings of rock
afforded fairly easy footholds for a
descent lost after a drop of a few
hundred feet the declivity became very
gradual urged on by an impulse which I
cannot definitely analyse I scrambled
with difficulty down the rocks and stood
on the gentle slope beneath gazing into
these sticky in depths were no lighted
yet penetrated all at once my attention
was captured by vast and singular object
on the opposite slope we froze steeply
about a hundred yards ahead of me an
object that gleamed Whitely and the
newly bestowed rays of the ascending
moon that it was merely a gigantic piece
of stone I soon assured myself but that
was conscious of a distinct impression
that its contour and position
we're not altogether the work of nature
a closer scrutiny fooled me with
sensations I could not express for
despite its enormous magnitude and its
positioning in a base which had yearned
at the bottom of the Seas since the
world was young I perceived beyond a
doubt that the strange object was a well
shaped monolith whose massive bulk had
known the workmanship and perhaps the
worship of living and thinking creatures
and dazed and frightened yet not without
a certain thrill of the scientists or
archaeologists delight I examined my
surroundings more closely the moon now
nearing the zenith shone weirdly in
vividly above the towering steep that
hemmed in the chasm revealed the fact
that a far-flung body of water flowed at
the bottom winding out of sight in both
directions
almost lapping at my feet as I stood at
the slope across the chasm the wavelets
washed the base of the cyclope and
monolith on whose surface I could now
trace both inscriptions and crude
sculptures the writing was in a system
of hieroglyphics unknown to me and
unlike anything I had ever seen in books
consisting for the most part of
conventionalized aquatic symbols such as
fish eels octopi crustaceans molluscs
whales and the like several characters
obviously represented marine things
which are unknown to the modern world
but whose decomposing forms I had
observed on the ocean risen plane it was
the pictorial carving however
that did most to hold me spellbound
plainly visible across the intervening
water on account of their enormous size
were an array of base reliefs whose
subjects would have excited the envy of
a door a I think that these things were
supposed to depict men at least a
certain sort of men though the creatures
were shown disporting like fishes and
the waters of some marine grotto or
paying homage at some monolithic shrine
which appeared to be under the waves as
well of their faces and forms
I dare not speak in detail for the me
remembrance makes me grow faint groan
desk beyond the imagination of a Poe or
a bore they were damnably human in
general our client despite webbed hands
and feet shockingly wide and flabby lips
glossy bulging eyes and other features
less pleasant to recall curiously enough
they seem to have been chiseled badly
out to a proportion with their scenic
background for one of the creatures was
shown in the act of killing a whale
represented as little larger than
himself
I remarked as I say their grotesqueness
and strange size but in a moment decided
that they were merely the imaginary gods
of some primitive fishing or seafaring
tribe
some tribe whose last descendant had
perished errors before the first
ancestor of the Piltdown on the and
earth or man was born awestruck at this
unexpected glimpse into a past beyond
the conception of the most daring
anthropologist I stood musing whilst the
moon cast queer reflections on the
silent Channel before me then suddenly I
saw it with only a slight churning to
mark its rise to the surface the thing
slid into view above the dark waters the
vast Polyphemus like an loathsome it
darted like a stupendous monster of
nightmares to the monolith about which
it flying it's gigantic scaly arms the
while it bow its hideous head and gave
vent to certain measured sounds I think
I went mad then my frantic is sent off
the slope wouldn't live and of my
delirious journey back to the stranded
boat I remember this
I believe our sang a great deal and
laughed oddly when I was unable to sing
I have indistinct recollections great
storm
sometime after I reach the boat at any
rate I know that I heard peals of
thunder and other tones which nature
utters only in her wildest moons when I
came out of the shadows I was in a San
Francisco Hospital brought thither by
the captain of the American ship which
had picked up my boat in mid-ocean in my
delirium I had said much but found that
my words me given scant attention of any
land upheaval in the Pacific my rescuers
knew nothing nor did i demon necessary
to insist upon a thing which I knew they
could not believe once I sought out a
celebrated ethnologist an amused him
with peculiar questions regarding the
ancient Philistine legend of Dagon the
fish gone but soon perceiving that he
was hopelessly conventional and I did
not press my inquiries
it is at night especially when the moon
is give us and waiting that I see the
thing I tried morphine but the drug has
given only transient Circe's and this
drawn me into its clutches is a hopeless
slave so now I am to end it all having
written a full account for the
information or the contemptuous
amusement of my fellow man often I ask
myself if it could not all have been a
pure phantasm a mere freak of Fever As I
Lay son stricken and raving in the open
boat after my escape from the German man
of war this I asked myself but ever does
there come before me a hideously vivid
vision in reply I cannot think of the
deep sea without shuddering of the
nameless things that made this very
moment to be crawling and floundering on
its slimy bed worshiping their ancient
stone idols and carving their own
detestable likenesses on submarine
obelisks of water-soaked granite I dream
of a day when they may rise above the
billows to drag down in their reeking
talents the remnants of puny war
exhausted mankind of a day when the land
shall sink and the dark ocean floor
shall ascend amidst Universal Panda
the end is near I hear a noise at the
door as of some immense slippery body
lumbering against it it shall not find
me
[Music]
[Music]
you